hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is hi I'm Samantha Watkins and this
is Tamra Jessa she reached out to me to
watch all of the Oscar nom so that we
can have an opinion and then we could
watch doctors together I did it for the
first year last year just like in
college in my fare time on my laptop in
my room and like I always watch the
Oscars every year but it changed the
game for me was knowing what all the
movies were and what people were talking
about so we have seen all the nominees
for Best Picture lead after lead actress
Supporting Actor Supporting Actress Best
Director and cinematography as well as
both the animated shorts and the
live-action short things like Best
Animated or like best foreign is either
really difficult to get a hold of or
it's just like it came down to a time
thing so yeah we didn't have to do a
week some women Amman times we're to
watch 16 movies yeah I am NOT a great
person for this kind of thing because I
solely choose it on just what made me
feel good yeah that's why I think it's
good that we're not kind of giving our
input on things like like editing yeah
I'm like I don't understand that we
can't ha we can't act like active we
talk about that this is my kind of
editing that's how I and the animated
shorts nominees are blind vice'
I hope I'm hey I was right borrowed time
purpose this pear cider and cigarettes
pearl and Piper okay so my pick is set
with pearl yeah that's my pick because
the others were cute and good and also
Ken you haven't returned home in Kent
yeah which I think I just in an animated
short I think me personally I just don't
respond to that intensity I think that
my pick has to be Piper just together in
a sucker for adorable baby animals I
like the happy one like happier the
nominees for live-action short our
enemies within that was a translation
for that one last then a Leticia of a
silent night sing and timecode I'm
really glad that we have an opinion on
them because I feel way cooler than all
of you much JK I don't you mean I just
were we're not just here to allow here's
the cookies were so much more enjoyable
to me than be animated yeah me too they
just said there are more to them yeah
they're really deeper messages I would
just go with like my gut my instinct Cal
you know just a name I got a name it was
filming now need for cinematography on
arrival la la land lion moonlight and
silence we both watched silence today
together yeah it's not gonna be visually
stunning but the other ones I think
struck me more I think that having not
been watching this movie thinking about
the cinematography and like I want to
realize like I'm not sure that it would
have really dawned on me to notice that
if such that aspect we don't agree on
this completely moonlight is one of my
top favorite movies my top three
favorite films of all time I really
really really enjoy the low-budget
workarounds that they had to do with the
cinematography I think that's really
cool but the story is what stood out to
me so yeah for cinematography I don't
think that's mix wallow and have to vent
in the opening scene anytime there's a
one-shot scene in a movie I'm
automatically just completely enchanted
by it I was producing rather than
sitting there in this movie is opening
and all I'm doing is watching like oh my
god it hasn't cut yet it hasn't still
going it has it cut yet oh my god that
entire first dance number was one shot I
so I think that is my pick yeah I would
agree I think all lines also my pick so
I mean I feel like I want to give to
Lion just be guy and was also one of my
favorite hobbies I saw innocent but I
think for cinematography and the
nominees for Best Director arm apologize
if I prepare a basis yeah Damien
Chazelle for what Lowell and Mel Gibson
for hacks are read crazy like nuts very
Jenkins for moonlight
Kenneth Lonergan for Manchester vertices
the one new villain you denis villeneuve
for arrival my choice right off the bat
moonlight for sure it was a low-budget
thing he was given awesome awesome
actors in an awesome story to tell as a
true story
and I think that was what he was given
he just did he went so far this movie
captured me in like the most subtle way
that just like built up while I was
watching a movie and it blew me away
but I have to say that Mel Gibson
surprised though she hadn't he almost
improved
yeah I am I have a different experience
with moonlight then than most people did
but I get for you yeah I was it was
really high job i watch it late in the
game I saw moonlight and I was so
impacted by it and then I found lala
land and I think I would have liked lala
land more if I hadn't have just been so
like shell-shocked from loving moonlight
so much and then going into like this
music that is so I was over examine I
think I will give this award though to
Damien Chazelle for Lalo man and I've
read so many articles and interviews
with him or you know Ryan Gosling
talking about him approaching him about
the concept and you know I just think it
was such such an incredible idea it just
became this incredible work of art and
the nominees for Best Supporting Actress
are Viola Davis for fences Diane Harris
for moonlight Nicole Kidman for Lion
Octavia Spencer for hidden figures and
Michelle Williams for Manchester privacy
oh my god I know I can't this this might
be my least favorite category actually
to pick well we do have a time I had no
idea
I've deliberated this I I don't know I'm
going to take out I'm gonna take out
Manchester been Athena Jamie she was
really good who's great but wasn't it
wasn't as impactful as the other women
she could have been just talked about
and not even been there and it we gotta
find if I'm going to talk to its Nicole
Kidman and Octavia Spencer it was like
everything I've seen Nicole Kidman in a
long time I think the only other thing
that we compared for me is a Moulin
Rouge but that's just because I love
that word my all-time favorite so they
the audience watching knows that
gaion missile critic Doug he hates me
really I know every time I love it - yes
sir - they're really funny I think
Jesse's I want to see this person win
this award I think I'm going to give it
to Viola Davis yeah let's see burger if
natalie portman want it I'd be like yes
girl you were so good
Rock run stay ahead of our Sean well
white girl I want you to talk to Avery
cinder because I love hidden figure so
so much yeah but I think that I would
give it to Nicole Kidman and the
nominees for Best Supporting Actor honor
March Alleluia / moonlight Jeff Bridges
hell or high water
Lucas hedges Manchester Revathy Deb
Michelle lion and Michael Shannon
nocturnal animal my first elimination is
Jeff ridges honestly my hair trees like
white oh man I think of seeing comment
on the characters and it is on Jeff
Bridges performance I like um Manchester
my to see a lot like I was a very solid
film I don't know that I've ever seen
Casey act like an anything and I think
he would learn so good so good
um I don't think it's going to be my
pick for any of these awards though I
think I will go to the words of that
film
his performance was incredible and very
moving
not always yeah I was inaudible he was
incredible so important one of my
favorite roles in the movie I love
difference between him and his the most
reason thing I've seen him in is in
cotton cotton mouth and Luke Cage on
Netflix and so like dynamic of an actor
she's so hard for me I think the only
reason that I give it to dump it all
over him is because of again like
presence in the movie yeah because
that's Adele has such a bigger presence
you're right you'd ever seen the oh no
longer it seems like he should have been
nominated for Best Actor yeah I'm going
to give it to moonlight okay you give it
to line which I if he would I'd be like
of course right yeah I'm sticking with
it with Margo I'd be like oh I'm a
nominee for lead actress are Isabelle
Huppert 4l ruth negga for loving Natalie
Portman for Jackie Emma Stone for lala
land and Meryl Streep's for foreign Fox
faster Jake I don't think Emma Stone is
my pick for lala land
yeah I agree I love
I'm obsessed with her and I don't mean
this as a diss at all but it's on huge
reach she's playing a you know
struggling after it's sold early um
which she can actually relate to and the
same with Meryl Streep I did she know I
could just be cut off oh what a fun
character to play it oh so funny she's
like it would effortless for her it
seems yeah which is not saying I wanted
to did take effort but you know he makes
everything she made norm another she
deserves her own category of awards why
she's Meryl Streep every year that she'd
just give her the Meryl Streep they
release so I think it's between loving
and Jackie II was a woman in the 50s
last woman in the fifth right he was
married to white man's like living it's
illegal life and it's a true story and
she says she hadn't captured this woman
that was actually a person and this
woman who helped shape history as we
know it
in a way that was going to do her Jess's
and her children who were gonna watch so
I just really enjoyed her silent
strength oh absolutely
what a great phrase silence ring and the
Natalie Portman Natalie for amazing not
only tackling the Jackie that we see in
history tackling the Jackie that we
didn't mean it said conflicts that she
goes through as like if someone who had
to custom it cheated this beloved
husband this she loved him the country
loved him yeah and then also she didn't
love him something yeah it's hard it's I
think the story of loving is more
important to me so I want to give it to
Ruth yeah Natalie did such junk about
and that's the issues that you're
looking at the story of the loving is
like I want I want authority of so much
knowledge yeah and I want this movie
gets so much acknowledgement based on
their performance we're about jalapenos
one was mad man yeah I mean she carried
the entire story on her back I have to
give it her income - and the nominees
for Best Actor are Casey Affleck
Manchester brother see Andrew Garfield
Hawks are ridge Ryan Gosling wallow and
Viggo Mortensen Captain Fantastic and
Denzel Washington fences what a gaggle
of men it was a gag oh I'm going to take
out Denzel Washington for me and I'm
also going to take Ryan Gosling out
Batman
learned how to play piano I mean next
month people don't talk about that
enough
the Affleck I don't know that I've ever
seen him anything and he blew me away
I'm just really an underrated actor for
me I think the doctors in between Andrew
Garfield and Casey Affleck so would you
give me where to vo you know my my with
Andrew okay here's a good idea word
commander ng nah nah I'm gonna slowly
convince myself together to Asian no I
kinda want to shoot we could eat a piece
you and then the Google Yahoo annex it
was representing representing both cases
each other need to mention these snub
that is joel edgerton as Richard loving
and loving because his performance was
incredible that's a dude acting yeah and
nominees for best film on arrival fences
hacksaw bridge hell or high water hidden
figures lala land lion manchester
privacy and moonlight i asked you many
minor line or moonlight lion l-'alamin
and hidden figures what did be funny if
I went with Manchester by the sea just
because like I don't really know any of
it I think we both thought lions was in
our group
let's not choose lines write myself off
the hook I think that's a good idea put
hey yeah we should pick two different
movies yeah I don't - me lay my fingers
in figures like how do we not know how
did we not know as women right you love
women right how do we not know that this
is how we got to space I left the
theater feeling like in power out of the
loop and you're so inspired
how does ha I was really good in this I
was like maybe another snub as well it
helps know that he had such a likable
character he did that's okay something I
want to mention and Forrest Forrest
Florence Foster Jenkins and my favorite
line was I some may say I can't sing but
no one can say I didn't say I want that
hard to stand yeah now you know all our
picks we put in the comments what you
think is going to wear so we would
actually both like to take back what we
said about that doctor yeah and change
although we had a Epiphany
and really that we're we were so wrong
you changed our knives our opinion yeah
I I confessed after in life
here's another one over Wow gorgeous
beautiful the enduring laundry tomorrow
bye